game number four socks and brewers and
this is one of those nights we really
wish you were here able to enjoy our
company and our weather because it's 76
degrees it is one of those summer nights
that you wish for and you hope for in
chicagoland sox are trying to win yet
another series against the milwaukee
brewers two games to one as it stands
right now but the sox have won seven
straight series against milwaukee
dating back to the year 2000 16 gio
gonzalez tonight
against the royals three and two thirds
didn't give up any earned runs five hits
had some problems with his control not
much actually all in all through well
gamble has shown in the short series so
far that he's a pretty good hitter
and he strikes out gamble quickly a
fastball right on the corner and one
gone two on one out for avacyio garcia
upstairs for a swing and a miss in
strike three two gone by strikeout 2-1
pitch to jerko in the air shallow right
center racing in now is mazzara he is
calling and catching and that'll do it
and there is josh lindbloom it's been a
while since he pitched two to the count
on luis robert the rookie
and a wave animus down he goes lin bloom
starts his night with a strikeout it's
jan monkatta now
her ball swung on fouled into the glove
of narvaez
it's a big hook from
josh lindbloom to up to down couple of
strikeouts
and now it's jose abreu and the payoff
and he chases it a strikeout
lindbloom strikes out the side in the
first inning here's arcia two on and one
out in the second no score
to left field eloy jimenez on the hunt
and he has out number two arceo lines
out
2-2 pitch
in the air left backing up on that one
is eloy jimenez he has a bead he'll make
the grab and that'll do it for the
brewers here in the second they threaten
again
lim bloom struck out the side in the
bottom half of the first lin bloom
and he strikes him out with a high
fastball
four in a row to start the game
lin bloom can he make it five in a row
to start the game oh
well placed little cutter and down goes
jimenez
man just hit the spot
[Music]
five consecutive strikeouts for josh
lindelof to start this game boy how
about the first base runner of the game
for the chicago white sox is nomar
mazzaro brings up leori garcia here's
the 1-0 pitch there's a high fly ball
into right field chasing matthias back
still chasing at the track wall gone
to run homer
leori garcia
leary garcia who offensively has been a
revelation this year big smile on his
face there always is he it's his third
home run of the year he's now driven in
seven
first and second one out for the third
straight inning
maybe the third time's the charm get
some action going right here jericho
whistles one into left center a base hit
yellets will wind it up he's going to be
set here comes the throw from robert and
yelich is in there what a slide yellich
slid around the tag of yasmani grandal
and it's 2 1.
liuri on the backhand side from the
grass with a heave and he's got out
number one
2-2 pitch
bounce again toward short this time up
the middle scoop there by larry garcia
throws in time to garcia
so leory's doing it with the glove he's
done it with the bat and he flashes the
big smile so he can go right he can go
left he's got a very strong arm if he
can go left now here's yellow who's
walked both times up tonight and the 1-2
yelich in the air left field got some
carry but jimenez oh he can't make the
play and it's a fair ball and now
jimenez is in the net
yelich
around second on his way to third
and he is going to try to score here
comes a throw and yelich is in there
and this game is all tied at two wow
there you go
we talked about this very situation when
the netting was installed
that when that came in you could have
some weird bounces that would normally
be
a grounds rule double
they would climb the net that is in play
and it did right there and it turns into
an inside the park home run for yelich
so garcia walks he's at first with one
away and here's jerko in the full count
and jerko hits it sharply down the left
field line it is gone
jed jerko with a two run home run
jerko with three rbis tonight he pops a
two run homer his first home run as a
brewer his first
or rather second and third rbis and the
crew has taken the lead so foster set to
work with runners on it first and second
4-2 brewers here's our cno
arcia a little flare right field that's
down a base hit
over to fetch it mazzara coming in to
score for the brewers is smoke and arsey
on the first pitch makes it 5-2 brew
crew freddie peralta is on to pitch josh
lindbloom's day is done alto's got a
good lather worked up already 3-2 pitch
and he got him a fastball right down the
chute
nice breaking ball strikes out monkatta
a yakker
back-to-back case for freddie peralta
made quick work of abreu and peralta
gets the strikeout dotting the outside
corner with a 96 mile per hour fastball
and freddie strikes out this side here's
zach collins now with two outs he's the
tying run at home plate peralta's 3-0 he
does have the green light a high fly
ball into deep right center field
backing up matthias at the track at the
wall and he leaps up and he makes the
catch right there at the barrier if that
ball is pulled we're talking three run
homer but it wasn't and we're talking
third out
just just got under it
enough
garcia sogard on the bags
and smoke first ball swinging fly ball
to the left this should be deep enough
jimenez throw will come to third yelich
will score
and the brewers add to their lead it is
six to two here's a big chance for mark
matthias with the bases loaded pitch to
matthias ground ball up the middle of
base hit that's gonna score a couple of
runs for the brewers the brewers are all
over the white sox right now
it's a five run lead right now for the
brewers eight to three in the bottom of
the ninth
going's a bouncing ball smoke's got it
and there is out number 27.